اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره الاخباريه من
العربيه قبل الدخول في تفاصيلها نتابع
كلمه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في
اجتماع سنوي موسع لوزاره الداخليه الروسيه
معقد جميع مجالات الحياه ومنها الامن
والديموغرافيه والثقافه وهنا التعامل يجب
ان يكون شامل ومعاصر وما هو الضروري
القيام به ايضا
حل جميع القضايا المرتبطه بالهجره
وجعلها جعل الحلول سهله
وعمليه الحصول على
روبوت بطاقات لامكانيات التواجد المؤقت في
روسيا
والتي بحاجه الى تشكيل انظمه سريعه وسهله
الفهم بالنسبه للمواطنين
من رئاسه الحكومه
تدعم العمل وتنسيق هذا العمل
وهذا يمكن ان يساعد بمتابعه الوضع الهجره
في البلاد الذي يهم الامن الوطني بشكل عام
حل القضايا المتعلقه بتطور البلاد مرتبطه
ايضا
بالهجره وما هي الاختصاصات التي تحتاجها
البلاد والاقاليم وما هي المهنيه ومستوى
درجه التعليم لاولئك الذين ياتون للعمل في
روسيا هذا يجب النظر به ونحن تحدثنا عن
هذا الموضوع ايضا
ولذلك اطلب من الحكومه ومن مجلس الامن في
روسيا وغيرها من
الشهاده المختصه الن
كان هناك زياره ووصول اليوم للرئيس الصيني
الى موسكو بزياره رسميه تستمر لي يومين
طبعا بدعوه رسميه من فلاديمير بوتين وطبعا
من المتوقع ان تكون هناك عده مسائل على
طاوله الحوار بين
الزعيمين من بينها العلاقات الثنائيه بين
الصين وروسيا والوضع العالمي الراهن وطبعا
موضوع الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا لشك
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الكرام لين كان اعلن
بانه الزعيمين سيتطرقان الى المبادره
الصينيه التي كان كانت اعلنت بفبراير شباط
من قبل بكين وكانت وقتها الصين تحاول لعب
دور الوسيط بايقاف هذه الحرب